the stock market closed more than 700
points higher on Friday with word that a
potential treatment for kovat 19 has
shown early promise but some other
numbers paint a grim picture of just how
hard the virus is hitting the economy
this week another 5 million Americans
filed for unemployment benefits that
raises the total to 22 million filing
since March there are a few parts of the
economy though where business is
actually thriving and some hiring is
even underway Jamie yuccas tells us
about some of the industries seeing
booming sales the project I've been
working on the most with more time on
their hands
Americans are hand crafting sweaters and
scarves more than ever
leading to a big demand for yarn in the
last month we have been able to ship
over 2,000 orders including orders to
our stockists from an average of 2025 to
an average of 90 100 orders a day that's
quite a bit of an increase luigi boccia
and jarred flood are the owners of
oregon-based company brooklyn tweed why
do you think people are loving knitting
right now knitting is a great meditative
act of self-care so people slow down the
repetitive motion does calm the mind
that might be why board games and
puzzles are also in high demand here we
got some people that are getting orders
off the shelf to ship out sales at the
puzzle warehouse the nation's largest
puzzle distributor have jumped 2,000
percent and liquor stores are seeing a
30 percent increase in sales of wine and
spirits people always need spirits to
keep their spirits up or to handle while
their spirits are down cooking is also
becoming a national pastime with people
sharing some of their favorite dishes
and recipes on social media food at home
is increased significantly more than 50
percent General Mills CEO Jeff harmony
says the company in charge of brands
like Cheerios and Pillsbury baking
supplies is seeing customers turn to
products they can make at home
how are you keeping up with demand the
real bottleneck is is making sure the
stores can keep the Shelf stocked and so
that's why you see a lot of our retail
grocery friends are closing their stores
a little bit early to make sure that
they can restock the shelves
there are even new job opportunities at
the company we're in the process of
hiring more people especially our
manufacturing plants are you concerned
about hiring a number of people for the
demand now and then having the way
people off no I don't think so the you
know demand is pretty good we think
it'll be in our business at home and I
think for home consumption or business
be good for for a while as for the
Brooklyn Tweed Company they have not
laid off their team of ten instead
they're all working round the clock to
get crafters what they want one person
can do it it's just with the volume that
we have right now it's it's a little
daunting so we're we're just taking
shifts and us as owners of the company
are coming in and doing some of the work
as well just to keep things moving you
could call it a DIY on how businesses
can cope while also providing comfort to
customers in quarantine for CBS this
morning Saturday Jamie yuccas Los
Angeles a couple other good nuggets from
Jamie on Brooklyn tweed they say while
they're doing well they know that a lot
of others are struggling so they've
instituted to pay what you want policy
and they're supporting local yarn shops
that were forced to close they've raised
ninety thousand dollars so far for that
cause General Mills has announced Jeff
that they're gonna donate five million
dollars worth of products to America's
struggling food banks and we know that's
been a real problem with so many more
people going to food banks now good for
them food banks need the help big-time
right now